a tonsillectomy is the surgical removal
of the palentine tonsils two structures
located on either side of the back of
your throat normally your tonsils play
an infection fighting role by aiding in
the destruction of harmful bacteria and
other germs that enter your body through
your nose and mouth the adenoids located
above and behind the soft palate play a
similar role the tonsils often become
enlarged and enflamed when fighting off
an infection this is a condition called
tonsillitis tonsillitis may be
associated with fever sore throat
painful swallowing and swelling of the
lymph nodes in the front of the neck
it is most commonly diagnosed in
children but can be seen in some adults
as well while there are a number of
indications for tonsillectomy the most
common is chronic or recurrent
tonsillitis chronic inflammation of the
adenoids often due to allergies may
cause blockage of the eustachian tubes
increasing the risk of middle ear
infections and associated hearing loss
and adenoidectomy is the surgical
removal of the adenoids tonsillectomies
and adenoidectomy x' are often done at
the same time when you arrive at the
hospital for your procedure an
intravenous line will be started and you
may be given a sedative to help you
relax most cases are done under general
anesthesia which will put you to sleep
for the duration of the operation a
breathing tube will be temporarily
inserted through your mouth and into
your throat to help you breathe
during the operation tonsillectomies and
adenoidectomy x' are rarely done under
local anesthesia in adults and never in
children
during your tonsillectomy your surgeon
will use a special retractor to hold
your mouth open and a tongue depressor
to ensure an unobstructed view of your
tonsils your surgeon will grasp each
tonsil one at a time with tonsil forceps
cut it away from the surrounding tissue
and remove it with the snare or a tonsil
guillotine clamp
electric authorization or clamps and
ties will stop any bleeding at the site
where the tonsils were removed this area
generally heals naturally without
stitches the procedure for an an annoyed
ectomy is very similar to that for a
tonsillectomy both procedures can
generally be done in 20 to 60 minutes
after the operation you will be taken to
a recovery room until the effects of the
anesthesia wear off which usually takes
about eight to ten hours it is not
unusual for tonsillectomy patients to go
home the same day as the procedure